- [Kelly] But you're musical as well.
Cause I've seen you sing in movies.
- Oh, stop.
- [Kelly] I've seen it.
So stop.
No do you love, did you ever
think about going into music
or have a band or anything
when you were like younger?
- You feel threatened?
- [Kelly] I feel threatened.
- No, I feel challenged
that maybe there's a duet in our future.
- Well oh my gosh, is that happening?
Are we finally doing this thing?
- This is finally gonna happen.
It could be from Greg to Kelly.
- I did a movie with Matt Damon about
these conjoined twins back when everyone
in Hollywood was making
movies about conjoined twins.
And it was this comedy, the
Farrelly brothers did it.
And at the end of the movie,
we get separated, and my
dream, Matt's an introvert
and I'm an extrovert and I have this dream
of doing musical theater.
So, Meryl Streep and I perform a number.
And the director says, "Hey, listen
I need you to record,
I need you to butcher
Billy Stewart's incredible
1966 version of Summertime."
So I actually did a full recording of it.
And so eventually,
I get a call from my lawyer.
This is years later, the movie didn't,
you know perform very well.
But years later I get a call,
a couple years later ago
I get a call from my
lawyer who says "Rihanna."
- What?
- [Greg] That's right.
"Rihanna wants to use part of
your song in her album."
She wants to kinda I guess it's called a--
- Rihanna sampled you?
- [Greg] Yes.
- That is amazing.
- She sampled, yeah.
- [Kelly] I've never been sampled.
- Yeah, so I'm sampled.
- Yeah.
People that are sampled are awesome.
- I thought we were gonna
like be on the road together.
(laughs)
I thought we had a whole thing.
I never talked to her again.
She just used it in the song
in one of the albums.
So it was, it was cool yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Greg and Rihanna.
Gregory. It's got a nice combo to it.
- Yeah, kind of like a shorter Gregory.
I like it, I like it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Were your daughters,
do they freak out that
you're on a Rihanna song?
- Ya know, honestly
the song was slightly--
- [Kelly] Inappropriate?
Is it one of those?
- Yeah, NR. It was mature audiences only.
So I didn't hear it for years,
and then now I think they're kinda just
discovering it now.
- So wait this got even cooler.
You got sampled on an X-rated song?
This is so much cooler.
(laughter)